do you think that lunch is made up of
leftovers more than any other meal 100
lunch yeah dinner leftovers dinner
leftovers or lunch yeah yeah you can
take my cold leftovers that's what you
have in tomorrow buddy for your lunch my
leftovers are good enough for you a meal
that's what it's saying uh I love
leftovers at lunch but I do not think
it's primarily what is eaten if you're
gonna eat leftovers you're gonna
probably eat them for lunch uh I would
say something sometimes sure yeah that's
what you guys we're on some today
bro I'm not you think everyone's against
you I always do
and they usually are let's be honest
they usually are no but I'm on the other
end of this couch a lot and a lot of
times I'm not and I get pegged to be
that I don't mean to Peg you I mean your
crosshairs a lot just by by inherently I
mean you're crosshairs you feel less
like you're only 50 accurate probably I
feel like listen man when I pick you
to pay really it's empowering